recently if we look at what happened
with coronavirus and kovat the pandemic
have you followed the uh uh what is that
the uh
the event 201 have you followed anything
with the event 201 you followed event
201 so if you want to pull up event 201
just pull it up on google
uh and and i'm curious to know what
you're going to say about this so event
201 is uh
hosted by economic world economic forum
this is public info this is not a
conspiracy theory or anything like that
this is just something everybody knows
about so event 201 was hosted this was
in october of 2018 okay october of 20th
in the john hopkins center's health
security and partnership with the world
economic forum bill melinda gates
foundation hosted an event 201 high
level pandemic exercise on october 18th
my birthday 2019 in new york new york
the exercise illustrated areas where
public-private partnerships will be
necessary during the response to a
severe pandemic in order to diminish
large-scale economic and societal
consequences this is october 18. look at
the suggestions
two months later the pandemic happened
look at the suggestions can you can you
you're on google
yeah let me uh what do you mean the
suggestion they they
well i don't wanna i don't wanna bog
down the podcast but if with this if
they go one step further yeah they gave
suggestions from their report and it was
to censor social media not allow discord
everything that happened the last two
years can you can you all right on
google go ahead and google i want you to
type in are we ready
no no not rare our
we
oh hi buddy
are we ready uh my name matt zeller
and then the word syracuse
okay uh yeah no no go back up to are we
already actually
um
my nightmare the experience take my name
out of it
put are we ready and then actually put
take my name out of it sorry and put
strategic
national stockpile
to circle back to what you were saying
while we're waiting yeah you know i i
think you're right yeah right there
thanks gerard hang on one second okay so
this is my master's thesis yeah
go ahead and scroll down take a look at
the date
oh six
all right so in 2006 this team and i
were hired by the united states house of
representatives on committee on homeland
security to evaluate at that point the
pandemic influenza response plan for the
united states and the poke holes in it
and to see whether or not it would work
and what we learned was that if a
pandemic ever hit this country we were
well and truly [ __ ] um is what we had
learned um
so
we we wrote this report and in our
report we don't choose it we didn't
choose a sars covid type virus we choose
something that was actually scarier
which is h5n1 so h5n1 is a bird flu that
has a higher lethality than ebola and if
it ever actually became airborne and was
easily transmissible it would be what it
would be like with the movie contagion
per trace like it would it would wipe
most of us out we wrote it based on this
the idea is that h5n1 arrives in the
united states via a flight coming in
from asia and within 48 hours is
everywhere
um and then through this report all the
recommendations in this were actually
ended up being enacted into law by
congress
one of the things that we proposed was
regular practical exercises teaming up
private industry
like you just saw the 201 exercise on a
regular scale to try to get government
and private industry to begin thinking
about how to work through pandemics so
that i mean i i don't think that there's
those types of events happened all the
time yeah but let me go back to my point
here so this is you guys just
jumped in and went to a bunch of
different directions let's stay focused
real second i'm trying to ask a question
from you because i want to know what
you're going to do
my biggest concern is
anticipation of what's coming next
because kovid ruined people's lives the
last two years i think that's absolutely
both sides would agree with your school
education kids okay we don't even know
the side effects of it for a long time
with youth on what happened today right
i mean like
my uh just my daughter yeah is home for
a year
and a half nine year old a 2009 year old
what does that do yeah to their
development in new york you're saying
yeah yeah no virginia okay in addition
to that she's been conditioned now to
see every single human being as a
potential threat to her well-being it's
very interesting you say that yeah
actually yeah yeah so we don't know what
that feels like we don't know what the
side effects of that we have no idea
what do you do with the kindergarten
exactly
and now california just announced it and
anyways california announced yesterday
they're getting rid of ella usc they
were with those i've sent these i don't
know if you saw that oh yeah yeah
they're getting rid of f and these and
they're going back to indoor mask
updates but but here's where i'm going
to so i'm looking at world economic
forum i'm like okay so you guys did this
october 18 2000 2019. two months later
the pandemic kids it's kind of weird a
lot of the stuff you guys talked about
okay let me put the hat on being a
little bit skeptic
recently they had another one i don't
know if you saw the simulation that they
did so have you heard of cyber polygon
have you heard about the cyber polygon
being ran by a world economic forum i
know of it yet okay pull that off cyber
polygon so we can look at that so cyber
polygon if you want to pull up uh uh
that's not the first one there's another
one you can go to cyber polygon is
uh a project that they're doing same
thing again they're testing to see what
would happen if there is a cyber
pandemic so they're calling now the
cyber pandemic so cyber polygon these
days as a dislocation in the other
example
in this environment the best strategy to
safeguard our future is to build up the
right skills and understand the risks
involved this is why cyber hologram 2021
was dedicated to secure ecosystem
development pat if i can for a minute
just so people know the world economic
forum is not elected bureaucracy it is a
it is a non-government organization yes
just like the world health organization
exactly so they have these great names
as if they're like the u.n as this is
some sort of elected politicians this is
some sort of collaboration of world
leaders it is not it is a
non-governmental organization this is an
international lobbying group that has
just amassed so much control over our
planet i mean the the control that the
world economic forum and you know the
world health organization have over our
public policy is insane to a degree
where sometimes it feels like they're
leading our public policy but they are
not elected officials these are not
politicians these are not people that
that are representative of any people of
any government it's a very very
dangerous group but anyway so they just
had a meeting and they did a simulation
if you want to go to the simulation that
we can read this is reuters article go
to the next one uh by the way these guys
met in july of this year which is quite
scary because every time these guys get
together and no no you just had it imf
the israel
tyler you just had it up yeah i xed out
just give me one second oh okay just
type in uh uh uh imf israel
uh type in israel okay there you go okay
so exclusive imf 10 countries simulate
cyber attack on global financial system
okay and this thing lasts like three and
a half hours if you want to go up a
little bit so jerusalem december 9
reuters israel on thursday led a 10
country simulation on a major attack on
the global financial systems in an
attempt to increase cooperation that
would help
could help to minimize any potential
damages financial markets and banks the
simulator war game and as israeli's
finance minister called it and planned
over the past year evolved over 10 days
with sensitive data emerging on the dark
web with the simulation also use fake
news reports that in the scenario cause
chaos in global markets and a run on
banks if you can go a little lower the
simulation likely caused by what
officials call sophisticated players
feature several types of attacks that
impact the global foreign exchange and
bond markets liquidity integrity data
and transactions between impostors and
expo
exporters these events are creating
havoc in the financial market set a
narrator of a film show so it's five and
a half hours that you can watch this
steve wozniak is in it some of the most
powerful people in the world are in it
right
do you know what they're saying would
happen if this was actually to take
place power shutdown you don't have
power no ac no phone no internet no
nothing we've already seen it banking
system
in the country
it's called hurricane called superstorm
sandy if you lived in new york
the power went down there were no atms
there were no credit cards you couldn't
buy gasoline no you could buy you could
i guess but it was thirty dollars a
gallon yeah and you had to pay in cash
right and if you didn't have cash good
luck it was a week one week it was chaos
okay how about unpack the chaos unpack
it i i
it was i mean they had to call in the
national guard it was that what i'm
saying is people who didn't live there
they don't know unpack it you couldn't
like imagine you need food right so
right now you go down to like the
grocery store you go you pay with your
card right there's no card your card
doesn't work so okay you got to get cash
well the atms are out of cash and they
don't have power to begin with so how do
you buy food you're hungry what did you
guys do like like i was working for
christy
you were working for chris christie at
the time so what did you do i wasn't
there i i was i was in new york i had
friends who were who were telling me
that they would literally
they had like rations once you eat
through your rations what what happened
was capitalism yeah people came from
other states yeah some people
volunteered other people put a whole
bunch of gas in their pickup truck from
from pennsylvania went down to jersey
shore and was like i got gallons of gas
for 30 bucks and then there was this
whole thing and the price gouging and
the legality of it but people would
fight over like over atms like when atm
was like working and spitting out cash
they were like fist fights they would
get into it because do you know what the
wildest thing was
uh chinese restaurants delivered yeah
yeah it was nuts yeah people were
watering not everything was closed down
but but chinese restaurants were
delivered
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]